and I just remember even when I was
super young like 17 I went to this
conference about the flood
and I'm standing in front of this like
you know it's like uh post-grad whatever
student giving us a lecture on the flood
and she said there's a version of the
flood in every single culture
and then she said that's the proof that
it didn't happen and I was like what
what was that jive together like how is
it that this is a universal story but
you're using it to tell me that the
Bible story isn't true and I'm like
there's something missing here uh and so
then I came to really understand
symbolism just basically as the
patterning of reality
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
hello everyone this is Sarah from
Hamilton and I am very happy to say that
today we have uh Jonathan pegeot on the
channel and uh we have him here to talk
a little bit about his perspective on
symbolism theology what the Orthodox
Church uniquely has to contribute to the
discussion about the role of symbolism
and interpreting creation the way that
relates to biblical Theology and
especially I want to talk about his
perspective on universal history and the
way in which symbolism frames our
understanding not only of the history
that we find in scripture but also the
history of all Nations and how they're
brought into the Community of Christ so
welcome Jonathan to the channel thanks
for being here it's great this has been
a long people don't know this has been a
long time in the making we started
exchanging like a year so more than a
year ago about a year it's good that
this is happening I know yeah it's a
real blessing so um tell us about
yourself your background how did you get
into
um Orthodoxy and this particular way of
framing theology
yeah so I grew up in uh you know in
Quebec which is a pretty secular place
but I grew up in an Evangelical world my
father was a Baptist minister
who converted from Catholicism kind of
at the in the 70s so
um you know so it's interesting because
my my I grew up in a very intellectually
honest and curious home my father was
always asking questions I was thinking
so we kind of grew up in that that space
and I think that's what fostered both my
brother and I's
you know when we reach our late teens
and 20s we started asking a lot of
questions and started wanting to
understand scripture more deeply and
that's what led us into our exploration
of symbolism in my case more the
Affliction of art because I was studying
to become an artist and just struggling
to square that with my my Evangelical
Faith but then also with the world of
Contemporary Art and so discovering
traditional Christian art really was a
revelation to me
um and then through that and through
reading the church fathers especially
certain fathers of course send Gregor
Nissa and Saint Ephraim you know saying
Maximus the Confessor
um really kind of discovering the idea
and my brother was reading a lot of
rabbinical texts at the time uh and so
really discovering in some ways the
Bible as a as a world view rather than
just as a text to be interpreted from
you know rationalist point of view and
so trying to see the Bible as a pair of
glasses you know rather than like I said
something to interpret so so that's what
kind of led me on this path to to uh to
understand a Biblical symbolism
so did you ever have a crisis of Faith
where you know you weren't really sure
whether Christianity was true
um or was it a smoother process than
that for you
it's interesting it's like I wouldn't
say it was a Christ of faith I would say
but it wasn't it was that was I guess in
a way that that was the problems that I
was in my 20s I was reading trying to I
was had this intuition of mysticism and
intuition of of a more mystical approach
to to Chris to the to religion let's say
first and then but at first you end up
reading Gnostic texts right because
that's what is shown to you you read
Buddhist attacks and Sufi tax and then
you're like what's going on like it's
how is it because I knew I was a
Christian I was like how can I be a
Christian and then I find something
that's interesting you know in the in
these kind of uh strange texts and
obviously after a while I discovered
that no it's all there it's all there
and the Jewish father is like anything
of value that you can find in these kind
of more esoteric Traditions is there in
the church fathers and you know and then
you don't have to deal with the weird
stuff that comes with these kind of
esoteric Traditions so
and so you converted to Orthodoxy around
that time so yeah I converted to
Orthodoxy in 2003 started going to an
orthodox church around 2001.
um and uh yeah when I read so I read uh
I read the a text called tradition and
traditions by Vladimir lawsky and it's
weird because it's a pretty technical
text but it that really nailed it for me
it really encompassed you know my vision
of what I how I saw Revelation its
relationship to Art and to external
you know how the internal the external
uh fit together you know how silent and
word into body and and space works and
so it just was such a a revelation for
me that that I read that text and I it's
like I kind of knew already I was
Orthodox I was going to become Orthodox
and then it was just a question of
playing it out
and were you a big Bible reader as a as
a young person
um maybe not in the same way that
Protestants had kind of wished I was you
know like how they want you to read like
certain chapters a day or whatever I was
never into that so much like I did have
a deep love of of Christ and a deep love
of scripture and I also for some reason
have a good memory and so it's like I
kind of have a map of the Old Testament
in my mind there are some places that
are a little that are a little hazy but
I have this map in my mind and so uh so
I yeah I do read the Bible but I'm not
like even when I was young I wasn't one
of those like it was interesting like I
didn't like the idea that in some ways
that the religion the reading of
scripture was like the ritual that
replaced whatever traditional ritual had
been there in the Catholic church and I
found that weird but yeah
okay so what is the big idea then behind
symbolism what do you mean by symbolism
and you know how does that actually play
out concretely you know when we're just
living our daily life our daily life
yeah so I think and this is some I mean
you probably totally we I'm sure we 100
agree on this
it's like there's a problem that we had
in I would say 19th century type
Christianity and then early 20th century
Christianity is because of because of
materialism for some reason there's this
tendency to emphasize the
the this historicity aspect like it's
like you know people go out into the
desert they find these statuettes and
they find these old tax and you know
they're having all these technical
arguments about whether or not something
happened and how did it happen and and
you know like is Moses is that his
actual name or is it like a name that
was handed through tradition and all
these type of arguments which I always
found just so boring like I just found
them so boring when I was when I was
younger and didn't care much for that
but then there was also this other
strain up here which was kind of liberal
protestantism which was trying to show
these patterns in scripture and how
there's literary patterns in scripture
and they were even doing it in a way
to Discount the historicity of it right
so it's like I can see a pattern in the
story therefore it didn't happen and I
just remember even when I was super
young like 17 I went to this conference
about the flood
and I'm standing in front of this like
you know it's like uh post-grad whatever
student giving us a lecture on the flood
and she said there's a version of the
flood in every single culture
and then she said that's the proof that
it didn't happen and I was like what
would how does that jive together like
how is it that this is a universal story
but you're using it to tell me that the
Bible story isn't true and I'm like
there's something missing here uh and so
then I came to really understand
symbolism just basically as the
patterning of reality it's that that you
know we experience the world through
patterns there's no way of around it you
know if you want to tell the story there
has to be a beginning and an end and
therefore the way in which let's say the
infinite details of the world condensed
together has to be teleological and
therefore it has to have a structure and
that structure is not is the structure
of your life it's the structure of
everyday life now the difference between
your everyday life and let's say a movie
or a movie and a Bible story is that
there's a condensation which happens and
there's also like a focusing on stories
uh that are epically manifesting that
truth right so so like the stories in
scripture they're made out of the same
stuff as your everyday life it's just
that they Point them you know you know
it's like a burning Shining Light on on
how God reveals himself in the world and
so that's the way that I understand
symbolism
it's interesting that you mentioned that
your brother was reading Jewish texts
um when you were kind of working on this
working through this stuff together
because one of the things that really
strikes me about certain
um Trends within contemporary Orthodox
Judaism is the way in which they
emphasize the fact that the mundane is
precisely where we should expect to find
God most intensely right because if the
world was really created in its entirety
by God then we shouldn't expect to find
him more so in the kind of obscure
esoteric parts of the world but it's in
the most common things in creation that
we meet God most directly so yeah but
this is being an example but there there
has like I think that I think that
that's probably true but there's also a
reality to the reason for Tabernacle
worship for example is that the
structure of Tabernacle or Temple
worship is there to focus like it's
there to kind of focus so that you can
see it and so so the problem I think
that's because I hear that a lot like
you hear that in kind of in in kind of
new agey circles right it's like God is
everywhere and all that stuff and I
think that's true but you know there's a
reason why we have a kind of hierarchy
of
of of an order of of manifestation you
could say so it's so that it's to help
us encounter God you know even in in our
daily lives so I think both are true
it's like on the one hand you know
Tabernacle worship and Temple worship
and also let's say the the order of a
church you know the hierarchical order
of a church is in some way like a type
of anchor that will help you engage with
God's presence in the world in a more
concentrated and and Powerful way so
that you can then in your everyday life
you know have these moments of surprise
where you know the grace of God just
pops and just shines and you you have
these these moments of uh of Revelation
in every day everyday experience yeah so
it's a way of focusing your eyes to see
the world as it really is what do you
say something like yeah or focusing your
attention in general and your body and
everything and your your attention is a
good way a good way to use that word
yeah yeah so um you've made a fair few
videos on kind of biblical theology or
whatever considering you know biblical
theology how would you say that you know
this project relates to some of the
stuff that's been done by
um anthropologists like Mary Douglas on
Leviticus
um or stuff like that what's what is the
relationship between biblical Theology
and what you're doing
I mean I think the what I'm doing
what I'm doing in some ways is just
connecting like that's what I think I'm
doing and so you know if you look at
and I don't want to cast any stones or
anything but like let's say you look at
something like the Bible project for
example like what they're doing is great
like they usually get it right like so
many times they get it right but then
once then you'll hear sometimes as if
there's all they get it right in terms
of the pattern and the story and the
structure like the cosmic structure in
which the Old Testament is written but
then they all often will then Express a
confusion
at like how our world isn't like that
right it's like so here's the structure
of the Old Testament here's how it works
and it's like well you know we we
understand it but now like we basically
don't live in that world and I think
what I'm trying to do is to tell people
no you'll still live in that world
you really do still live in that world
and not only that but you if you just
have if you're direct your attention in
a certain way you will notice that you
still you can still have the same the
same experiences and insights that are
that are described in the in those texts
yeah and one of the things that's
striking to me about what you said about
the way in which people argue against
the historicity of certain texts is that
it seems to me that when you look
outside of scripture if you look at you
know just Christian history there are
certain moments in Christian history
which would lend themselves to being
written in a typological or symbolic way
so you know the battle of the novian
bridge you know it has these analogies
which are very strikingly parallel to
what we read in Exodus but it seems to
me that the narrative itself lends
itself to that kind of analysis yeah and
then what happens which which is
hilarious which you could imagine a
historian saying well that must not have
happened because it's too much like the
flood story like it's too much like I'm
not the foot but the crossing of the Red
Sea yeah there's an interesting like
there's something that happened about 10
years ago which is a good example of
this so it's sad because it is related
to our situation now and it's sad so
when Pope Francis was first elected he
had the ceremony and if you saw it he
was standing there and he had on his
right hand a boy dressed in blue and on
his left hand a girl dressed in red and
both of them they they they let go of
these doves into the air and the reason
was because they were praying for peace
in the Ukraine okay so they were praying
for peace in the Ukraine and they let
these doves go out in the air and as
soon as the doves were released a white
bird and a blackbird attacked the doves
within seconds and this is all like
they're like pictures of this like it's
just something that everybody
experienced and so you could say really
like if is that not like a actual
mythological event I mean that's a
mythological event and it and it not
only is it mythological but it's showing
itself to be truer and truer as time
progresses
and so would it would if you told that
story to uh to a kind of 19th century
historian today like in 10 years that
they they just tell you no that didn't
happen because it's way too mythological
in its structure
yeah if you read you know josephus's
Jewish War it's just filmed with these
kind of narratives of all these Omens
which were happening and things and just
recently you know in relation to Ukraine
I mean who knows what's actually going
to happen but I saw people sharing these
video of this huge murder of crows which
was flying over Kiev and people you know
were kind of spooked by it but there's
something in the wiring of the world
which seems to actually create those
correlations
um and but it's it's it's funny because
people some people who'd listen to this
would think okay now Goku magic right
and so but it's interesting to think
like
the people who say that what happens is
because they think that human beings
actually don't exist in the world
right they think that human beings don't
exist in the world and that the the
structures of human meaning are not
connected to the way the world actually
reveals itself so because of that they
can't they can't comprehend how there's
a relationship between natural patterns
and natural processes and things that
happen and human consciousness and human
meaning making right you don't think
it's weird when like a bird knows when
to fly south why do you think that's
weird you don't think it's magic like he
doesn't he doesn't he doesn't uh so if
humans have a capacity to Intuit
patterns and to and they have ways of
showing that like why is that so weird
to you I don't know why it's so weird
yeah I mean and people will often say
things like well we are pattern seeking
animals well of course we are because
there are patterns in the world we have
to be able to seek those patterns I mean
it's just you know it's a non-statement
really
um so I wanted to also ask you
um how you see what you're doing
um relating to something like idealism
because I saw you had an interview with
Bernardo Castro which I thought was so
interesting because I've found him to be
such an intriguing writer and I never
really thought of you guys in the same
you know context but it was great to see
that you guys have connected or had a
conversation what's the relationship
here
so it's interesting like a lot of people
how can I say this a lot of people
didn't totally understand what it was
that I was trying to do in that
conversation I get it it's fine it's
like I'm not an idealist in the naive
sense I'm just not like I do believe I
believe that the structure that's
described in the Bible is actually the
best way to describe it right the notion
of Heaven and Earth you know and that
you have you have a pattern of
intelligibility and a pattern of a
variability or chaos or whatever like I
think that these these is the best way
to describe the world uh now I think
that what's interesting about Castro's
idealism is that
he collapses everything into mine but
the way he does it he does it in a way
that actually doesn't preclude the
existence of of what we but most people
would consider matter or physical
physical uh phenomena and so because of
that I don't feel the need to argue with
him on that I just want to see like in
his in the way that because I do think
that in some ways it's closer if you say
something like all things exist in the
mind of God like I mean that's a
completely Christian statement you know
it's a completely there's nothing weird
for a Christian to say that all things
exist in the mind of God and so if then
after that like we the way that we
discuss can be can be can be
differentiated I mean we just have to
see the categories he's using and if
they if they create some kind of heresy
or some kind of weirdness in them and I
think there's some things obviously I
don't agree with Castro for sure but but
I think there's enough to to connect
with what he's what he's doing to to
help people understand the inevitability
at least of him of intelligence like
that you cannot the world cannot exist
without something like intelligence or
consciousness yeah and and I think a lot
of people take when they hear idealism
they take that to me no matter is not
real or matter is an illusion but you
know the underlying presumption behind
that interpretation would be that uh uh
matter is something that's fundamentally
you know opposed to or totally separate
from mind whereas what I see that kind
of argument is suggesting is that no
matter is real but it's real in terms of
the qualities that it has in those
qualities are mental qualities that are
all unders that can only really be given
um content in terms of Mind in terms of
Consciousness yeah that's the problem
the problem is that there's a there's an
Insidious notion about what we what we
mean when we use the word matter which
is this this idea of this existent
existent stuff which has no qualities
and it's like no no that is like that's
out like this you know when it when when
God does describes you know when there's
the description of Heaven and Earth in
the the first chapter of Genesis it's
like Earth is emptiness and void right
it's it's not it's not something that
has no qualities it's it's a kind of
potentiality to exist in which the the
names or the identities you know come
down from heaven onto but it's like so
then matter doesn't properly exist at
least not the way that not in a simple
way yeah not a not in a simple-minded
way that it's like this this mud right
what do people talk about like this
the pre-cosmogonic soup or whatever the
way they describe is like no no sorry
none of that
so before we um get to the universal
history stuff I wanted also to
um ask you how you see your work as
converging with and diverging from the
stuff over at The theopolis Institute
because they have had a huge influence
on just the way I read the Bible when I
read James Jordan in 2014 it just kind
of changed my life it really introduced
me actually to really this kind of
pattern of thinking
um and then when I found your work it
was so interesting because it seemed
like these ways of thinking had kind of
been articulated independently from each
other and now that you know there's some
conversation going on I'm interested to
see
um how you think of what they're doing
yeah I didn't I think what they're doing
is great and I've had I did interview
someone from theopolis on my on my
channel that Alistair yeah Alistair
that's right uh and so I think that that
what they're doing is great I would say
that the difference and once again like
I don't wanna
like their scholarly work obviously is
way deeper than anything I'm going to do
like their attention to detail is I have
nothing to do with that right so I need
to be careful right I you know
um but I would say that I think that
would differentiate me from them is that
I don't think they fully grasp the
consequences of their main Nosh of their
main uh Vision so I think that that if
they grasp the consequences of their
their main perception about pattern and
how how that works I think that there's
some
I would think that there are some
Protestant positions that could no
longer be tenable and that's that's what
I do believe and so I think that
that although I love what they're doing
is say like if you you can see it like
make some if you want to like ask about
Mary right like ask about the mother of
God and then it's like good all right
and so I get it I understand but it but
if you if you were if you were taking
all these patterns that you see in
scripture very seriously like there's
some things at some point that it
becomes almost impossible not to see
anymore but I I still I celebrate what
they're doing like I celebrate their the
fact that they want to to bring
Protestants closer to liturgy like they
want to have Protestant celebrate the
liturgical year and so they have this
they I think a lot of the stuff they're
doing is is positive but but I do think
that's the big
yeah yeah no it's interesting for me to
see
um you know Peter lightheart you know
has I don't know if it's just recently
that he started saying this but I've
seen it put out some articles on the
Virgin Mary as the new Eve or things
like this and so when you've when you're
thinking in certain ways in scriptural
ways and when you recognize something
like Eve is described on the analogy of
the city of God she's built like the
city is built in the next chapter and
then that kind of explains why our
liturgical tradition is calling the
Virgin Mary the city of God and why
she's associated with protecting cities
like Constance Melbourne recklessly
intervening on their behalf it all
really rolls together in this beautiful
way and I think perhaps despite
themselves perhaps not
um the more that they've put out over
the years
um yeah I've read some of their early
work from just the 80s the less
distinctly Protestant it'd be
interesting to watch because I think
that so one of the things I've also
noticed is that they hesitate
to at least in my experience I haven't
read that much of them but they hesitate
to start to cite certain fathers and
they they hesitate you know because of
the allegorization let's say of
scripture uh and and as if some of the
typological readings the MIT is
arbitrary and it's like I get that but I
think that
so so a good example would be like
saying Gregory of Nisa it's like when
you read the life of Moses and because I
was reading it recently for some for an
exodus uh thing I'm doing and so for as
you read it he says things that look if
you if you're not careful they look like
he's just throwing it out there so he
says this this and then it's like okay
I trust sangria grenisa completely so so
some of the things I'm doing is trying
to like unpack the steps like I'll
unpack the steps for you I'll show you
like why the sandals that Moses removes
from his his feet at the burning bush
are the garments of skin and I can show
that to you in the text in ways that
saying Gregory doesn't doesn't go there
he doesn't have to right he doesn't feel
like it has to but it's like I I'll go
far like if you can't understand the
story of zipporah circumcising Moses's
son and putting the foreskin on the feet
you know it's like all these images like
they're all there it's just that Saint
Gregory doesn't necessarily tell you but
you can you can kind of point that out
for people to help them kind of unpack
some of the typology and show them that
it is extremely coherent and very deeply
set in the in the text
it's interesting that you mentioned that
text in particular because I remember
reading life of Moses years and years
ago and coming across that passage where
he talks about
um being deified by walking behind God
in other words by following him and how
that were and it was so compelling as an
image but I had to kind of put it on the
Shelf as far as the text goes because
like okay well I believe this but I'm
not quite sure how to fit it all
together and then you know one evening a
couple of years ago I realized wait a
second you know haha you know means to
walk right and what does God say to
Abraham walk before me and be perfect
and where is the walking being done it's
being you're walking in the way of the
Lord and there's this theme of
journeying behind God as he leads you
through the Wilderness and Moses and all
kinds of things about Moses's
orientation in relation to God and His
orientation in relation to Israel are
happening in the text and as he pointed
out defeat are so important and then
God's feet are described in all over the
biblical text and the way that that
relates to just his activity and his
pattern of life and yeah because the
glory of like the pillar in Exodus like
we have to understand that the pillar of
cloud and the pillar of fire is the
glory of God we see it later right when
the Tabernacle described and it says
like the pillar descends on the
Tabernacle like that's the glory of God
present in the Tabernacle so Israel is
literally walking behind God into into
into outside uh leaving Egypt yeah yeah
and the classic phrase for obedience to
God's instruction is turned neither to
the right side nor to the left side and
then the Chariot of God is moving in
exact right angles and then it fills
Ezekiel and he's moving in exact right
angles as well in the Book of Ezekiel
and so all of these kind of steps as you
put it
um are there in the biblical text and
then the church fathers they just say
the conclusions like ah I want to
reconstruct all of this but I guess
that's the benefit of having an
unlimited amount of paper or writing
space we can just say all these things
now we don't have to just throw it out
there and leave it for people to figure
out so yeah that that's that's really
exciting
um so uh moving from Biblical theology
biblical theology you're looking at the
history mostly of one specific Nation
right the Christ as he's embodied in the
life of Israel how does that expand
outwards into Universal history and what
do you see the project of universal
history as fundamentally being about
yeah so as people know you know Richard
Roland and I started this series which
we call Universal history and it really
was interesting because I've been in
interested in this idea of universal
history for years like just really
really interested in and then I met
Richard Rowling who was like he's not
just interested I mean he he's got it
down like he just knows it right he's
just such a he's he has all the skills I
don't right so he so he has all the
details and all the all the tags and
everything all the references so the
idea like let's say in terms of um the
for immediate understanding is to see
how when people would convert to
Christianity in uh you know in the
history of Christianity one of the
things they try to try to do was to
connect themselves to the Christian
story usually and and also to Rome it
was like Rome and the Christian story so
how can I connect my ancestry back to
the the um the Trojan War and how can I
connect it to the Bible somehow either
the flood or some some character in
scripture and you know and when you look
at for example Jeffrey monmouth's uh
text you know those first chapters
that's what's going on but the problem
is that
all cultures kind of have that modern
historians what they do when they read
these Chronicles is that they just chop
out the first part ignore it as if it
doesn't even matter and then start with
like the real history and then see the
rest as kind of mythical history but our
contention is that no the mythical
history will actually be the pattern by
which you'll be able to understand the
regular history right the connection
that they give themselves to the ancient
and the way in which they do it the
characters even that they that they say
they're related to will become a kind of
uh first pattern which will then explain
the rest of the of the stuff and so I
think that that that's that's what we're
trying to do in some ways is revive
these actual existing Universal
histories so you have for example The
Apocalypse of pseudo Methodius which is
this kind of grand history of how all
the peoples connect and you know there's
the place of Alexander the Great and
Ethiopia and all these these nations but
you see uh Echoes of that for example
like in the in the the history of Great
Britain or Scandinavian history
different different countries will have
their own version of it and so we're
trying to some ways bring that out
because one of the things that happens
in these Universal histories is that
they will not they will not
um they won't have the tendency to
completely deny their Pagan sources so
they will connect both to the Christian
Source or try to reorient the Pagan
ancestry into a Christian thread and I
think that that's very useful for us to
understand the way that Christianity was
even understood by people's uh that
would converting it's like no we're not
we're not trying to make you become
something completely else than what you
are what we're trying is to reorient
what you are into the into something
which is good into the good and so I
think that all of that is you couldn't
can be useful for us today to understand
how they did that why they did that
um and and it can give us a key at
understanding even why the West even
exists you know
so was there a particular
Nation or story which kind of stood out
to you as a glaring example of this
pattern of this phenomenon going on
well I think so I think the most glaring
example is Alexander I think Alexander
is probably the one that is the most
visible because what happens in the
story of Alexander the Great is you know
because he's this great conqueror and he
kind of unifies the world together there
are all these legends that end up
spreading about Alexander
and then they start to be collated and
collected together and one of them is of
course they come from different
countries but one of them is that
Alexander uh goes to Jerusalem and he
encounters the priest of God and when he
encounters the priests of God he
declares the unity of God like he makes
a kind of Declaration that God is one uh
and this is a Jewish Legend probably I'm
not sure they even know exactly where
all the Legends come from uh but what
happened with that is that because of
that Alexander is in the Quran like
Alexander is a character in the Quran
and so Alexander then becomes this
figure so there's another story for
example of Alexander who makes these he
takes these four Griffins and he wants
to see what's in the heaven so he he he
ties it like a rabbit I think to the end
of a stick and he puts the stick up and
then the Griffins fly up to eat the the
the the the the rabbit and and he
ascends up in the heavens and then as he
gets near the highest fears like towards
this fear of Saturn I think he hears a
voice telling him
this is high enough like a man should
not go any higher and so then he obeys
the voice and comes back down and so
it's like this kind of mythological
storytelling you know gets included in
Christian uh storytelling and so
Alexander becomes an image of the
righteous King who knows
who is ambitious who is who can manifest
the the positive aspects of the
political class but also knows his limit
like knows where to stop that he
shouldn't
transgress the the boundaries of what it
is to be human and so that's a great
that's a good example and then his
Legends become some of the most popular
stories told in the Middle Ages all
across the world from from England to
India basically
wow in the India oh yeah yeah they're
Indian versions of the of the of the uh
also it's also because of Islam like
there there's an Islamic you know the
because of the Mogul uh Empire you have
these you have these these versions I
went to see a show in London by the way
a few like a month ago which had all
these Legends like all these these
manuscripts from everywhere in the world
and all these different versions of
manuscripts like it was a it was an
astounding show like I was so so happy
to be able to see it uh and yeah there
were versions from from basically all
the way into Persia because you know you
took over the Persian Empires down into
India there were virgins from from
Byzantine Empire there's a whole massive
one of the most eliminated manuscript of
the alexandrian legend is this massive
Byzantine
um book that has the whole Legends all
Illustrated very much like icons like
they're it looks like icons but it's the
story of Alexander it's it's amazing
one of the images that um I found really
intriguing in just looking at what the
church is doing or has done in relation
to specifically Greek cultures that you
know image in the prophecy of Noah as
God enlarging yaphath and bringing him
into the tent of sham
um and it's really interesting to me
that you know Paul whose profession is a
tent Builder is the one who specifically
sees himself not just as uniting Jews
and Gentiles but he's always using that
phrase Jews and Greeks
um and it seems to me that that's
something that's really integral to the
church's Mission and that when they
convert when people converts it's not
just that their history is now kind of
cut off and they start new at that point
but they're actually bringing something
in something which God has been growing
in them for a long time and it's part of
the church's mission to you know bring
that into the body of Christ and so I
think I think that's exactly right and I
think that that's in some ways
representing that story and representing
the reality of it in the legend right in
the in all this this gathering in of the
of the ancient stories you know is a way
to also answer the the the secularists
or answer the atheist who who says
Christianity is just just wiped out the
old practices or or you know it's like
that's just not it's interesting because
you have both it's so fascinating on the
one hand you have some people that are
accusing Christians of wiping out all
the ancient practices of you know being
these horrible you know controlling uh
civilization Bringers and then you have
the other people saying ah Christianity
is just uh infected with all these Pagan
practices it's basically just a Pagan
religion with uh with the Jewish veneer
it's like okay well choose which one you
know I don't know it seems like it's
actually somewhere in the middle where
it's it's exactly the way we're
describing it
and so what what does this mean then for
you know an American right if you're an
Orthodox Christian Living in
Appalachia or Southern California
um what is universal history have to say
to you
I mean
it's interesting because you could
actually see it you know in the very way
that that Orthodoxy manifests itself In
America which is that America
man this is people are not going to take
this the right way please wait till I
finish the argument before you react to
this so America is something like the
end of the world
right America is the end of the world
and because it's the end of the world it
it manifests the extremes one of the
extremes that America manifests is
something like the the horror in
Revelation okay I said so this idea that
America is a land of of excess a land of
mixture a land of of lack of cohesive
identity right is something which is
true of the way in which America exists
okay so you you it's hard to avoid that
and so what happens it's it's negative
but it's not just negative right it's
just reality it's just a description of
what is there and so the way in which uh
Orthodoxy manifests itself in America is
like that it's it's it's a little
confused right because it's a it's
trying to preserve all these separate
churches inside of America without
having the capacity or will to join them
together into the single church that
they should be
um and so we have to be I think as
Christians as Orthodox Christians in
America we have to not be naive about
that and understand that that is the
reality of Orthodoxy at in the end of
the world you could say right at the end
of the world that's what happens
um and so
there are
although it's a problem there are some
advantages to that as well there are
some aspects of that which can be can be
used to to or at least being aware of it
can help us
um and so there is a possibility in
America and I see it like as an artist I
see it we also have the possibility of
synthesis which other places don't have
the possibility of so you can understand
that so in let's say if I was a Russian
if I was as some people have described
me a Russian Orthodox icon Carver right
then I would have this one tradition
which would be the Russian tradition and
I would have to see myself in
continuation of that but I'm not I'm an
American or North American Orthodox icon
Carver and because of that I actually
have access to all these threads that
are coming down and I have the
possibility that other people don't of
re-tying them together in a way that
reveals something Universal about the
Orthodox tradition so I think that
that's the advantage of American
Orthodoxy uh but it it also it's also
born of something which is clearly a
disadvantage which is this problem of
multiple uh jurisdictions kind of
coexisting in this same space that's a
really exciting image for me as a you
know someone who's into biblical
theology because it seems that you know
the two kind of competing
um ends of the moral Spectrum you could
call it are two kinds of mixtures right
so you can have like a mixture like an
image of Baphomet where it's just
obscene you have all these different
categories but you're kind of locked
onto each other and it's diabolical but
then the high priest's garment is just a
mixed fabric from top to bottom or the
Tabernacle or the temple it's got all of
these different kinds of things which
are being brought together or you have
the land of Eden in the land of villa
and you're bringing the resources of
both of them together and it's
integrated into something holy and
that's the imagery of the restored Zion
and the prophets of the Nations coming
from the ends of the world to put all of
this different stuff on one in the same
altar yeah and relating it appropriately
to each other so I think that and the
image of the the of Babylon is an
interesting one because of course the
inverse of that is uh the bride Zion
right yeah is a different kind of
mixture yeah
um so that's a really intriguing I think
productive way of framing both like the
the challenge but also the opportunity
of living in this wild weird place yeah
well we the way that Christians I mean
we have something in Christianity which
we call Union without mixture right the
the sense that we have the possibility
in Christianity of joining things
together without confusing them and so
and I think that in Revelation you have
two images of that yeah you have two
images of civilization you have one
which is a riding a beast right
that's a one image and that is the
excess of both right the the excess of
civilization which is controlling which
is devouring which is naming right it's
like I'm gonna give you a name that you
can't that if you don't you don't use
you will be eliminated and on writing
that is licentiousness and chaos and
mixture and all this stuff the the image
of the Heavenly Jerusalem is a beautiful
image of Multiplicity and unity
collaborating and then like it actually
says that you know the the kings of the
of the world or the kingdom of the world
offer up their crowns to to the city and
so it's as if this gathering in of all
that is good from all the nations into
one space that is that is all attentive
to the lamb right that's all attentive
to to the the to God ultimately and so
it's like that's I think that's the
image of kind of symphony that the
church can become
so what
let's say that your missionary in the
foreign country if you have to if you
have something to say or if you don't
have anything to say no no go for it if
you if you're a missionary in a foreign
country
um is there a way to kind of utilize
this way of thinking in such a way that
it's not arbitrary or you're not trying
to tell a people their own story or is
it something that just has to kind of
arise organically yeah with a
christianized culture
yeah that's a tough one huh because
one of the problems of the modern world
is the acceleration of course and the
hyper connectivity and so in some ways
it's difficult I think that
traditionally these things happen very
organically
you know it's uh so I think that you
know
I think that for example the
evangelization of Russia it was like I
mean I mean the tremendous task of like
creating a new language and and kind of
giving that language to the the roof so
that they could
have some kind of cohesion was a very
powerful thing uh and then what happened
is that that inevitably became flavored
or connected with the local culture so
there's there's an interesting image
that Saint Ephraim the Syrian uses when
he talks about the Waters of paradise
and he says the Waters of paradise right
when they start at the top of the
mountain of paradise they're pure and as
they move down the mountain they become
more and more mitigated but none
although they're mitigated they're
nonetheless right the influence of the
mountain down at the place where they
are but they end up becoming mitigated
and I think that that's probably the
best way to understand how Christianity
should connect to local cultures is that
it's like you establish the source and
then the source flows down and starts to
water the lower parts you know the the
and and that happens in a way that the
water become mitigated but they don't
lose their completely lose their flavor
um but the problem today is that
everything's so deliberate hard to
so for example a good a good example
would be let's say I'm I'm a Greek
missionary I go to Russia and then I
convert the tsar and I'm like Yay all
right so now I want to build a church so
it's like I'll get maybe a few guys from
Thessaloniki or from from Constantinople
to come and build the church but I'm
going to need the local materials I'm
going to need the local people so the
flavor of the church will become Russian
very fast but now you could just prop a
church you could proper you can prop up
an athenite Church down anywhere in the
world and it'll look like it just sprang
it right out of the of the mountain so
there's a way in which technology and
and modernism makes it more difficult
for that to happen naturally we might
have to be more deliberate about it you
know if we if we were doing that yeah
and you can see perhaps you know Divine
Providence in that and as you have to be
more intentional about this kind of
stuff that brings it more and more to
your awareness which allows you to see
the actual significance and what's going
on there
um one of the images that I don't know
if you have you ever read the
um book the patient ferment of the early
church
it's one of the images which was
striking to me about that you know was
that of fermentation and that it's a
process which you know begins kind of
invisibly but then as you get towards
the end it speeds up very very rapidly
and then soon you've got a fermented
drink and it seems that you know as
we've entered into the modern world with
interconnectivity and all that kind of
stuff a lot of these things which used
to happen very slowly now just happened
like that yeah and even though it looks
less organic to us it's just it could be
you could see it as the same sort of
process but just going on at an
incredibly
um quick speed yeah relative where it
used to be
um you can see like the churches in
Africa like the churches in Ghana and
stuff like that you can see how now the
church has been there for a few
generations and so all of a sudden the
tonalities will be different like you
can still hear it it's connected it's
still connected to to to
let's say to Byzantine culture but it
has like you said it's fermented and so
now the tonalities are different The
rhythms are slightly different and so
there's this slow embodiment you know
within the the culture of the source but
it it's it's hard because of political
pressure today we would want to do it
very fast but I think if we do it too
fast we can also run the risk of making
major mistakes uh so I don't like I in
some ways I I have great Mercy on the
missionaries that are out there because
how do you find the right that right
balance you know how do you find it I
don't know yeah yeah I know in when I
was in Kenya it was
um a number of years ago I remember at
the Cathedral one of the interesting
things as you mentioned the tonality was
different I know that the Archbishop
there was very intent on getting the
Liturgy translated not just Swahili but
also all the tribal languages and stuff
but I remember during the Eucharist uh
and I'm not commenting one way or the
other on this but I remember the
Eucharistic hymn was uh nothing but the
blood of Jesus which was so
interesting to me just in terms of the
way that actually you know catches I
mean it's a good you know it's a good
Eucharistic hymn as far as it goes
that's a bit yeah I wasn't so I lived in
Congo for four years and I I had the
opportunity to be in the in the jungle
like in the four we're almost in the
forest when uh for pasca one year I was
there doing all Holy Week and so and I
didn't even know I was being able to go
to church for for for the service but
then someone I knew found a church for
me drove me there Saturday afternoon
it's like there's this church like like
I said this one was definitely had
fallen out of Heaven from Thessaloniki
and it was just like there and and I
went in as like Fresco's like Greek
frescoes everywhere and everything was
so Byzantine like and very well done
like very well done Byzantine but then
it was only you know when we got to the
the the when we started to kind of
celebrate the resurrection we started
saying Christ has risen then it was like
okay then Africa started to appear and
like women started utilating and like
and everybody was like it was was making
noise and I was like okay I'm back we're
back you know so so I think that these
things like yeah they'll break out like
no matter what the missionaries try to
do you know the the more the more
connected pattern will break out
ultimately you can't totally stop it
yeah yeah
so you have a I think you have a pretty
substantial part of your audience which
is not Orthodox I mean I know just a lot
of Christians and just a lot of
interested relatively secular people
watch your content what do you think
um what what makes the Orthodox Church
unique as kind of the air of this
symbolic interpretation of the world and
what
um what makes the the home of people who
um would see the world in this way
well I think I mean I think that there's
a more there's a practical way which is
in some ways the orthodoxist to just
preserve this language more I think that
you know if you'd gone back a thousand
years in the west you would have found
similar structures like in terms of the
the Liturgy and the architecture and
everything was all there and typological
reading was all there but I think that
ultimately there's a reason why
Orthodoxy was able to preserve this and
it is the image of fiosis and I think
that theosis is the
is the key right it's the key to
understanding that the world is full of
his glory and we're not kidding like
we're not joking about this we do
believe that God you know upholds
creation you know that his word is
hidden in all manifestation and that
that is not arbitrary that it that it
looks like something it looks like love
it looks like order it looks like a song
and so it's like so so I think that that
the the centrality of fiosis in
Orthodoxy I think is what has preserved
the possibility of of helping people
see this and encounter it and practice
it you know and I and I don't think that
because I do I think theosis is real so
it's like so how can I say this so even
though other Christians don't
necessarily emphasize it or sometimes
don't believe it I still think that's
what's keeping them together so so I do
think that you can still encounter you
know traces of that in other in other
Christian Traditions but Orthodoxy
definitely has the the greatest Symphony
of it
yeah yeah and I mean I think you see
um providentially I mean in the history
of Western theology in the 20th century
some people I think people can miss just
How Deeply shaped a lot of Western
theology was by the fact that you had
all these Russian Emigrant theologians
coming over and in certain ways drawing
out threads that were still there but
were kind of Dusty and now you have
people in the west talking about theosis
in terms which would be very
intelligible to the church fathers and
to to Orthodox theology today
um and so I think that's really
providential and I think you know that's
to the extent that we can see what God
is doing
um it's just intriguing to me that lots
of people seem to be independently or
relatively independently talking about
symbolism in the way that you know the
church talks about it in the way that
you're talking about it and so it's just
it's not that's not a coincidence I
think that we are in a Kairos moment I
think that you know in some ways the
ground had was prepared for a very long
time and that you know you know 20 years
ago my brother and I were talking about
these symbolic ideas about patterns and
everything and we could couldn't talk
about it with anybody you just couldn't
because not only did they not understand
what we were saying they didn't
understand the subject like what exactly
we were talking about and so now we find
ourselves in this moment where like you
said independently in some ways these
kind of fruits have grown up I don't
know why I don't know exactly how that
happened but it feels like like all of a
sudden I can talk about things and you
can talk about things and people know
what you're talking about they
understand it it and it's coherent and
you know you can talk to bernata Castro
and you can say something like you could
say something as crazy as you know the
son of man sits at the right hand of the
father and he'd be like yeah yeah you
know I get it you know I get it and it's
like how did this happen like how can I
talk about logos and talk about you know
this type of this type of imagery and
then you know even a scientist will
understand the structural relationship
I'm trying to make and we'll we'll be
able to at least cap at least understand
that I'm not just spouting off woo-woo
magic there's a structural reality here
to what I'm talking about if you can see
it
so where do you see this going if you
have any thoughts on that in the next 10
15 years yeah well
yeah I think things are going to get a
lot darker I'm sorry to say I don't
think I think things are going to get a
lot worse
um I think a good way to explain what's
happening now is something like
you know something like a there's a
re-enchantment that's happening but that
the re-enchantment is not just good news
it just means that the barriers that
materialism had placed around reality
are breaking down right like the the
materialist barriers that were kind of
that work that held things together for
a while that made us really proficient
in creating machines and civilization
and everything that that's starting to
fray and crack and then you know
narrative reality is is flooding back in
uh and so I think we're going to see
very dark things on the horizon but I do
think that at the same time it is the
ground in which
you know
um a Revival or whatever you want to
call it of Christianity will happen and
so I do think what we'll see is we'll
see the seeds grow
in terms of a deep understanding of
Christianity but we'll also see the
world around us becoming
more and more hostile to it and more and
more dangerous so sorry I see very I see
light in the long term and a lot of
darkness in the short term yeah well the
C.S Lewis you know he mentions how at
different stages of the great conflict
between Christ and his enemies you know
we fight that battle in different ways
and so when people stop taking
naturalism seriously I mean seems dirt
and dark things no longer have a
motivation to operate in a concealed way
yeah what kind of direct conflict that's
more visible and scarier yeah yeah so
um let's wrap up by talking about where
you're going next what's what's On Your
Horizon what projects are you working on
so I mean one of the things that I'm
mostly interested in doing now is
telling better stories so I you know I
wrote a graphic novel and I'm also
writing fairy tales right now that's
kind of what excites me because I I talk
about we need better stories but then I
also don't want to just be the guy
analyzing and complain about how
horrible culture is so so I think that's
the thing that's really exciting that
I'm part of uh there are a lot of things
happening in the next in just in this
year that are exciting in the sense that
you know there are opportunities that so
for example like this just this in the
next few months I'm going to speak at
Princeton seminary I'm going to speak at
at Oxford uh possibly Cambridge and it's
like what right what's going on what's
Happening you know but it's like okay I
mean let's go let's do this right I mean
what why not you know it's it's like uh
and and let's not
you know let's not dance around it let's
just let's just go so so in some ways
I'm excited to see people understanding
what it is we're talking about and being
excited about it so
so uh that's what that's what I I think
that that's the thing that
in some ways that that kind of drives me
too because I'm like oh wow you know
so yeah so that's what that's what
that's what's happening in the next
in the next year let's say
wow that's really exciting dude did they
reach out to you or yeah so different
different people reach out to me for
different reasons you know and it's of
course let's be honest like it is in
some part because of Jordan Peterson so
Jordan has you know has been this
strange kind of intermediary character
where he's not really a Christian or
kind of I don't know like it's not
totally clear at least yet uh but he's
pointing and he's kind of
and and and so I always say it's kind of
like King Cyrus who says you know hey
that Temple of yours you know that's
pretty cool you should go build it
something like that uh and so so that's
also how for sure to attract attention
to what I'm doing and and ultimately
hopefully to attract attention to this
basic way of thinking
um
and so so if that can happen and we can
see
that say Bible scholars feel less
because I'm not a Bible scholar so it's
obviously I'm not the one who's going to
do the work but I think that if we can
have Bible scholars understand that this
is a key way of seeing the world that
that illuminates a lot of the of the
biblical text then then we're going to
see a lot more right we're going to see
more of the scholarship and also like we
talked about before I think ultimately
and hopefully more of understanding the
consequences of this way of seeing the
world in terms of liturgy in terms of
church in terms of what it means in
practice so
yeah well thank God and uh let's all
pray for more light than darkness and
the near future and the far future so so
I have a question I have a question for
you what about you like how do you see
the role you're playing in terms of this
because you're way more detailed than I
am like like I've watched my videos I I
love just how much you master the text
and so what do you see that's in front
of you like what do you see as the that
which is calling you right now uh yeah I
think I just have to focus in on
biblical studies yeah I go through these
periods where you know I'll be all in on
like biblical studies and then it'll
kind of expand outwards from there but I
want to really kind of dive deep and
systematically in some very specific
books
um and uh God willing I'll be offering
some stuff this year on something like
Exodus or Isaiah just going line by line
through the text and kind of doing the
sort of thing we were talking about in
terms of looking at the allegorical and
symbolic meanings and kind of step by
step showing okay this is why the text
says this is how we can know that it
says this and then kind of framing that
in certain contexts in an apologetic way
like this is how this is taught in the
Bible this is how we you know know that
the church you know has an authoritative
tradition but doing that in such a way
that it's not just you know a series of
proof texts or here's yeah reasons you
shouldn't be Protestant or whatever and
doing it in a way that is
um uh that's beautiful you know yeah so
that that they I mean for me
I had a huge crisis of faith when I was
in my early teens and then just
struggled with doubts for many years
afterwards but it was when I really
started to study the Bible in detail I
perceived this kind of Beauty in it and
this just coherence that seemed like it
came from you know another world
um and so I'm really excited about uh
just showing that and showing how that
works out and uh hoping other people can
be drawn into the world of scripture
yeah that's great and I think like you
said I think it's a strange moment where
that not only is possible but it's like
people are strangely excited about it we
did this it's we so we did this Exodus
seminar right you know about this like
we did this exercise seminar for the
daily Wire yeah and so we get around we
got like imagine pitching this to like a
producer 10 years ago right we're gonna
have seven people sitting around a table
none of the people are actual
theologians like none of the people are
Bible scholars and we're going to talk
about Exodus for 16 hours
and we're not going to get through the
book we're just gonna get through half
the book and then
like then we're gonna get back together
I'm gonna do it again and we're going to
talk about the last part for 16 hours
it's like try selling that but turns out
it's the most popular special on daily
wire
yeah it's like because it's like people
are hungry they're like give me
something give me some food man give me
something good yeah and you know I think
some of the most profound insights that
I've heard on a given passage have been
from people who really don't consider
themselves much of a Bible reader even I
mean James Jordan once described how
like a five-year-old girl said hey if
man turns to dust and the serpent eats
dust doesn't that mean the serpent eats
people and he goes wait a second uh
Satan is a roaring lion seeking can be
made of our the idea of Satan eating the
dead Giants or people eaters and things
like that it's just a five-year-old girl
who you know puts things together that
we wouldn't usually put together and so
it's super exciting not just to help
people see that but you know to draw
them in
and help them produce insights of their
own because yeah yeah it's an
accelerating kind of compounding process
that's great well ah man I'm happy to
hope you find it'll be good to do some
of the the more difficult books and some
of those books yeah Whoever has the guts
to do judges you know let's do that oh
yeah yeah
but even like the the so I was
interesting at The Exodus seminar you
know I with all my love for Dennis
Prager so it's like you know I asked him
like I even outside of the conversation
outside of the film conversation I said
and I said who's the figure in the book
of
of Daniel like who is this figure that
sits at the right hand of God you know
and that has that looks like the son of
man and he was just like well you know I
don't know I don't know who that is and
I was like it's interesting like it's
like it's there right it's right there
in the text so what is anyway so there's
some definitely things to to elaborate
on and if you look at the iconography
you've probably seen this but the
iconography of Christ like the early
images of Christ are all mapped on to
right the visions of the prophets in the
Old Testament so if you see the image of
the Ascension in the rabulla gospels
sixth Century it's like Crisis ascending
into heaven and under him is like all
these wings with eyes and and heads and
wheels and it's like yeah that's because
they knew that this is what was going on
like the image divisions in the Old
Testament yeah were revealing what
Christ was and his Ascension into heaven
is him returning in the same spot that
is described in those uh in those uh
prophetic Visions yeah yeah and it's
just thing about that Vision in Daniel
is that you know Daniel and Ezekiel are
in certain ways twin books they're yeah
at the same time you're written I think
in the same time Ezekiel mentions Daniel
by name and that little phrase you know
uh one like a son of man has one of its
closest parallels in Ezekiel one I saw
one seated above the throne in the
likeness of a man uh and so you know
these
I think your scripture has a very
um specific and precise Theology of
things like the angel of the Lord you
know it's not just this kind of vague
thing which is hinting at you know
something which is only becomes clear
later there's really a lot of
specificity to it and how it relates to
the Tabernacle system and all that kind
of stuff so yeah that was something that
I found really exciting when I was just
starting to see the beauty of scripture
I remember reading Isaiah 2 and it said
that the Nations will Cast Away their
Idols when the Lord Rises to terrify the
Earth and he alone will be exalted in
that day and I looked up those words I
mean there's lots actually of
Resurrection puns I think in the Old
Testament God Rises and then things
happen you're like oh wait that happened
in the resurrection of Christ but when
it says the Lord alone will be exalted
in that day well you just go a few
chapters later and you're to the end of
the book and it says that the servant
will be high and lifted up and he will
be exalted and then he will sprinkle
many nations that the nations are
sanctified things like this so it all
just rolls together in this way that you
know makes an icon of Christ and yeah
inside the Old Testament on its own
terms is really compelling I think in
showing that there is actually a
coherence to this Statistics so father
Stephen DeYoung on my channel recently
you know he he he studied this quite a
bit too and he was saying that it was so
intense that in the in the early first
second century uh Judaism as it was
burgeoning kind of being born that they
they started writing commentaries about
how that you know this image of the son
of the son of man sitting you know uh
next to God like that God punished him
for it like you know you shouldn't sit
you know you should stand like there's a
mistake like you shouldn't be sitting at
the the right hand of God right but it's
like it shows you the Deep the Deep idea
that the idea that this figure that
Daniel uh that Daniel and Ezekiel see
right the fact that it's sitting means
it's not an angel like it's at least not
an angel in the regular way there's no
way like it's not a servant servants
don't sit and that's why we also like we
just don't have that way of thinking
anymore but like servants just don't sit
the one who's sitting is the one who's
being served and so
it's not anyway it said it's it's it
would be interesting to to go deeper
into it but yeah there's definitely
there's a lot to say about about that
yeah I mean it's a book inspired by an
infinite God so there's an infinite
amount of things to say about it and
that's what's so exciting is that you
never run out of material that's right
that's everything thanks for the
conversation this is a lot of fun I
enjoyed it yeah and I hope we can do it
again sometime sure definitely all right
thanks so much